welcome to chess and psychology from
studio d
uh should be fun huh all right so
um okay today i want to show you a
very interesting game between
oh boy am i muted please don't be muted
uh let me double check
please don't be muted i am not muted
great
i was muted at the beginning probably
okay
so um today i
am joining you from my
house well current house i'm changing
dorms uh
on friday which is gonna be fun huh with
my lovely cat
fishy uh so those of you who have been
joining us on twitch for over the past
week ten days you have you've been
uh introduced to peachy and his charms
of jumping around and
hopefully putting up a good show not
sure if he's gonna do that today we just
um he just ate like half an hour ago so
probably sleepy alright so
besides the cat show that i had for you
i also have a very interesting game that
was played between petrossian and
unzikar
this one is one of my favorite games
i've watched some other games from
undercarr
definitely a lot more games uh have been
watched from petrossian
so i kind of um i think this game was a
very interesting
kind of like just clash between them
it's the game that's happened in hamborg
1960 so if anybody likes to
add it to their own database feel free
to do so
um and yeah this game
i kind of like the king march title
because
as you will see the king is gonna have a
very very long march
we've had some other games we've seen
some other games like this
in different classes when the king was
just running around
or not castling but this one was
especially interesting
to me oh someone from nigeria wow that's
pretty late there thank you for staying
up
all right so uh let's jump in and start
looking at the game
so so far we have a somewhat of a normal
opening
um torah i believe uh torah yeah
and if it was c3 would be call it
and finally c4 well now this is actually
like a queen's gambit
so never mind um
yeah thank you for joining i um i have
the chats right here so if i'm
moving around i am just look trying to
look at the chat
more frequently well uh all right
so this is the position that
so far the opening turned into
so if you if you play this with dwight
feel free to um discuss it in the chat
or as black what do you play personally
as black i don't do this c6
i don't actually play the um queen's
gambit as often i usually just play
nimble indian or granfeld
but i usually try this last scare line
with bishop e7 knight e4 and that's
something that
i actually wanted to talk about
previously
in one of our classes we did like it um
would you like a poll
if we should do lasker or not and
unfortunately it lasts alaska
opening last but uh this is something
that i definitely want to show you guys
in soon future hopefully next next week
now that we are kind of setting the
grounds for it wow it's all over the
place
brooklyn india norway san luis
egypt whoa egypt is one of those places
i've always wanted to go and i just
never got the chance
but i love the history all right
so uh anyways
let's look at the game that happened
here
um so far everything is normal just
white's trying to develop and for short
castle
black is developing aiming for short
castle
and knight belongs on c3 no questions
there
h6 i completely agree with that as well
just kicking the bishop away from the
pen
um well knight d7 seems to be the
the logical place especially because
we're not doing this c5 anymore so
night gotta go to d7 oh i've been to
portugal actually
in 2017 yeah right after gibraltar i
went to portugal
the lisbon open it's pretty interesting
i liked it
all right so um for any of my camp kids
who are here
we have looked at some um we have talked
more in depth about pond structures
so like isolated ponds hanging ponds
upon majority attacks minority attacks
but we've talked about different pawn
structures in camp so if anybody's here
feel free to show off your knowledge
but so question for you guys now
at this uh cd5 do you think cd5 is a
good move
or do you think taking with eve would be
a better choice
or even knight i think knight is also a
interesting choice so what do you guys
like between these three
i think ed5 might be
a little bit more solid compared to
10 knight takes but
does anything about c35 worries you
because if you like c takes d5
then maybe you could tell me um
something like
what do you plan to do with your bishop
in this position
where are you going to place this bishop
yeah um i do think e takes d5 is also
better
i think 95 is also doable but
not really sure what to do with this
bishop that's the biggest problem when
you take with the c
because what are you going to do now b6
bishop b7 your bishop is still pretty
blinded
um b6 tried to do bishop a6
possible but it's kind of like a kind of
like dreaming because even if that
changes this score is weak
this knight can jump and i also think um
the other thing to think about
is that in this position white is pretty
ready to do stuff in your queen side
right
all the pieces are kind of pointing
towards your queen side
so when you take with the pawn it kind
of already gives off a little bit of
more ideas for white to start thinking
about some new squares to jump around in
so i don't really like taking with the c
just because it would give my opponents
way too much chances and way too much
hope
so that's why we could take with e
even taking with e now this is the
crossbar pawn structures and knight on
d7
isn't ideal so i understand the
hesitation on taking with the knights
with the palm
because uh in crosswalk pawn structure
there is another
idea to do like knight a6 knight c7
knight e6 do like a g6
knight g7 put the bishop on f5 because
we kind of want to just get this bishop
to f5 in the crossbar pawn structures
right
so that's something kind of interesting
that's i
kind of would i mean i understand not
taking with the e
because your bishop is kind of hard to
get to f5 but taking with the knights
um i'm a little skeptical on this
just because let's say take and then
just bishop d3
maybe knight f6 you still end up in this
crossbar pawn structure
i mean a little bit easier because you
don't see your knight on d7 isn't really
blocking stuff as much
but still at the same time this bishop
is still a problem you don't really know
what to do with it
so i mean i guess all i'm trying to say
is i understand the confusion
but you still gotta you shouldn't
let your opponent just get advantage
so easy like this and yes that is a
sleeping cat in the background it's not
really sleeping he's more like
napping he's awake he might wiggle his
tail for us a little or
get up and give himself a small bath as
he has been doing in our twitch channel
when i'm streaming
um so all right back to the game
patricia knows how to use this advantage
and he wins for bishop d3
already putting the bishop in the good
diagonal black tries to create something
in the queen side
but i think it's kind of it's a little
bit of a stretch
um i'm going to ask you what do you
think
white should do after b5 but
let's i'm going to tell you a little bit
of
something that's better than b5 so
knight b to actually be better than b5
and the idea is that you're simply gonna
put like knight c6 relocate this knight
because previously you couldn't play
knight c6
because there was a pawn on c6 right but
now you could try knight c6
and maybe go for b4 square
something like that i i mean
i don't know if i would actually play
knight v8 in the real game
but might be it actually is a little bit
better
right now you could think about
something like knight h5 as well
like knight is try try to kick this
bishop around a little
maybe taking with the pawn this is
getting a little uncomfortable for my
knights g4 coming next
gotta play g6 yeah i don't really like
this
either so all right let's just keep
looking at e5 so
b5 what do you think is the best move
for white
i i guess the main thing you should
consider is are you actually worried
about the move b4
because if you're not really worried for
from like blacklink b4 then you don't
really
have to stop you don't have to stop it
so you don't really
need to actually think about a3 so
keep in mind how we talked about a
little bit earlier on
how all the white pieces are kind of
like
marching on the queen side or basically
keeping an eye on the queen side
so maybe we could think about something
that
um tries to give us some actual targets
in the queen side because
we only have like we have some spatial
advantage we need to try and convert
it into something like a real target to
attack
and um oh i see a camp kit here how are
you doing chess gig
yeah you should you should know this
we've talked about converting
advantage in our camps haven't we
so i see an a4 i see a3 i see e4
i think e4 is interesting but not right
now that's something that you gotta do
way way later
now you have to focus on the queen size
uh yeah also e4 could have some um
potential problems such as take
and if you take back now bishop b7
and now rook c8 is coming attacking your
k your queen
it's getting uh black is getting some
room to breathe
we don't want our opponent to have
chances of
breathing well just over the board
so what now uh i don't like the idea a3
because it's um it's a little bit
pointless
when we play a3 we're not really like we
kind of want him to play b4 we want to
provoke b4 because we want to go after
this a6 pawn
so i do like the idea of a4 good job on
thinking about a4 and you do want to
provoke this also if taking that a4 now
this is very weak you just take it with
the knight
you got c5 square you got b6 to try and
put
jump into this is a very weak pawn you
can just play queen e2 and start
attacking this
no this is very good this is very very
good for
white so let's look at b4
what do you want to do with this knight
after b4 you basically have
um well i kind of want to say two
choices you can go e2 or a2
uh you could you could consider d1 or b1
but d1
you're not really going anywhere after
that and b1 you simply just go to d2 b3
at max which is not i mean
b3 is interesting square but you can
achieve that with either of them with
um knight e2 or a2
um so
what do you want to do with this knight
now
where do you think this knight can go
because pretty much um when you play
something
black is going to try and play a5 soon
depending well
not really depending on where you go but
i think the main thing to understand
right now
is that even wherever the knight goes e2
or
a2 is not a permanent space so
you're trying to relocate that night to
another square
i'm kind of waiting to see your opinions
on that mysterious square
in the chat
so that's why i'm saying chess kink i
don't necessarily think a2
is a bad square because a2 is not the
permanent place you're just going to
relocate it
so yeah exactly thank you prince
los strado we do want to bring the
knights back to b3 so knight a2
went with knight to e8 i understand that
because bishop c7
could be pumping up and
then we are simply doing this
knight e8 and
finally we get this knight b3 so
we finally got the knight to b3 r knight
is in a
very interesting position this knight is
kind of stuck here because if you move
it you get bishop c7 then you lose a5
um you also can't really do knight b6
because well
knight c5 is coming up so
um what about now
let's say black plays bishop a6 now
what do you want to do do you want to
exchange do you want to take that bishop
or do you want to simply
um wait for opponent to take your bishop
on d3 because you can't really avoid
that bishop exchange so you're
basically choosing between whether or
not you should take it first
or wait for our opponent to take it
so what do we think we should do here
okay so i have a rooksy one i have a
take on asics
all right interesting i do think it's a
good choice to take over here
to be honest we can because that's
something that's happening
and if we wait for opponent to take it
then the opponent can also get rook c8
but if we take it first now the stroke
is also misplaced and can't really go to
c6 next move
so that's kind of why i
don't really um
i mean i didn't really like the idea of
a long opponent to play rook c8
so now that the receipt i mean he can't
really get into the c
file with support i think that's a
better choice
but now we got to try and figure out
where to how do we want to relocate our
pieces
because this is a good bishop i agree
with that
this is a very interesting night the
night is in a good place bishop isn't a
good place
this night could also
be in a better place probably but what
about your queen so
the the pieces that we kind of really
need to
uh relocate is the queen and
possibly the rooks so
what shall we do now i do like the idea
of rook c1 to be honest
but the one thing that black does want
to do
is something on d6 bishop d6 maybe
knight d6
so we can't really stop that so all we
can do is try to make it harder for
black to achieve that goal
ah alright so i see rook c1 i see queen
e2
um not necessarily queen e2 queen d3 is
a little bit better
but i like your idea so after queen d3
let's say rook
goes to um
a7 and then we can
try to bring the rook on c1 so question
which truck do you think is better to
bring to c1 or does it even matter are
we gonna just double it up
what do you guys think we should do
[Music]
i also want to point out remember when
black played bishop a6 and exchanged the
bishops
like two three moves ago we were
thinking about
um probably black was thinking oh this
is such a good idea i'm gonna i'm
getting rid of my bad bishop
which was true at the time but at the
same time now all of these white squares
are
kind of um weakened so we can go after
it
all right i see i i like the idea of
bringing the rook
fc1 alright good choice
if we need to double up we will double
up but it's let's just keep it safe yeah
let's bring up the effort good choice
everybody so
let's say now um black was knight d6
what shall we do keep in mind we can't
take it
if we don't take it now c4 and e4 are
accessible for black
so either you gotta protect those
squares or you gotta take that knight
so what shall we do shall we take on d6
or should we
try knight d2 all right i see some
knight d2 ideas
um i think the problem with playing
knight d2
is i don't
this might b6 somehow is bothering me
yeah you do get my c5 but still there is
a
good chance for knight c4
so this is something that i'm kind of
trying to
we don't really want to deal with like
yes we can try b3 take
take now bishop comes exchange so
yeah this is a good night up here but
again there's 97
trying to get rid of it so
i think the biggest question is um do
you
see the future of this game do you think
that in a long run this bishop is going
to be more useful than
a knight
so i think that's the only um that's the
only
thing to actually think about because
um it is kind of hard to give up this
bishop i agree
but it's
we kind of have to prevent um
have to give up this kind of strong
bishop to prevent
this blocking of c file exactly thank
you
as mentioned in the chat as well that's
very good point thank you so
take take earth c6
this is giving me some real good
flashbacks to the camp stuff that we've
done
some stuff about outposts just how to
use them
open file so this is a very cool gain of
tempe right we're just
getting this rook c6 and you can't
really
kick this trick away at the moment well
let me rephrase that you don't have a
good way of
kicking this trick away at the moment
because yes you can't play knight b8 and
that's what uziker played in the game
but i'm also putting your knight in 8th
rank and that's not really what we want
to do right
so um
so now what should we do with the rook
you have very limited choices so i'm
more like i'm
more looking like a something that could
form
or more of an idea or like so we do this
and then do that and then we have we
want that
something just a very short plan on
where
what should we do with our pieces knight
e5 as a blunder bishop takes e5
your rookies is still in huge trouble
careful
yeah rook c2 just bring it back and
then we are going to play rook c1
so um i think this is a very just
we can just do this uh i don't really
like that knight a5 has a
bit i mean i get that if queen takes you
have rook d6
so but even then there's queen c7 so
your rook can't really go anywhere
also what if earth takes so yeah be
careful
like i i understand that you want this
fork and you want to try and pick up
some material with it
but it doesn't work good eye for
thinking about
um the por the fork though
almost a pork haha all right so
we get this rook c2 now
knight has to come back because that
knight and b8 isn't doing anything
so nice d7 double up the rocks
let's say knight goes to b6 trying to
get to
um c4 now what do you think we should do
here
i don't really see a very effective way
of stopping knight c4 right away
so we could just play knight d2 yes but
your a4 is also under attack so i think
you have to prioritize on um
well what to save so
what do you think we should do now
um if you're playing knight d2 you're
losing a4
so careful with that
i see there is a lot of heat for e4 but
still you're losing a4 so you have very
limited choices yeah
queen b5 good job prince gotta do this
queen b5 defend
a4 and after that
um so now
we're also attacking a5 so black kind of
has to play this knight c4
now after knight c4 what do you think we
can do
is it is it time to start this knight to
d7 knight d2
idea or do you still want to
try and do knight c5 i guess
yeah i think it's about night um
i think knight d2 should be i think it's
about time good job chad
so after knight d2 um black kinda has to
take it right
because we're attacking this knight with
what one two three
four different um attackers and it only
has one defender so you
do really have to um
take so
after knight takes d2 what do you want
to take it back with
rook knight if you take it with knight
then where do you want to place your
knight
if you take it to the rook you do know
that you're just gonna play rook c2 back
soon anyways
yeah i think we do have to take it with
the rook because if it even if you take
it to the night we still have to bring
the knight back
because this knight actually does belong
on b3 and i think taking with the knight
is a little bit more pointless compared
to him with the rook because when you
take it to the night
you're also taking away this attacker on
here so there could be some clean d7s
compared to when there was this
if you take her to the rook queen d7
doesn't really make much sense anymore
well actually you could take there's a
steer for k7
um yeah never mind i don't like this i
don't like this for whites
nope let's not take that um i mean
hold on we can't just bring the rook
back still won't attack this there's a
c8 all right now i like this here it
goes rook c6 okay
so i kind of think um
i i think it could be simply um
like a i think it's a transposition
whether you take it at night or rook but
taking it with rook seems a little bit
more appealing just because
you keep the pressure on the knight on
the palm
so now
uh we already talked about queen the
seven
a little bit so let's talk about queen
a8
let's bring the rook back rook d8 keep
in mind something like rook b8
um it's not as appealing as it looks
because we can simply play queen c6 and
now this
end game is also much better for white
because that's a clear target now you
also
don't really have space black is very
defensive
so
let's say rook d8 now what
what do you want to do with whites
we've talked about converting advantage
earlier also a lot in camp
so i'm rooting for you chess king to
find a lot of these moves
um so in the camps we talked we actually
saw some different games about
that was related to converting advantage
and we talked about how you convert like
spatial advantage to structural and then
you
can kind of like transform it back to
material and then you gave up that
material that was a very interesting
game actually i might show it in one of
the youtube classes too so
ah good job chess king proud of you rook
c6
so after rook c6 we have kind of full
control of the open file
and so this is what i'm talking about
you see you have advantage
now you just have to figure out how to
put it into good use basically
uh ah gamer yes i i understood
that geometric c6 too so
now what shall we do with white keep in
mind this is something
that's this is kind of where most of
the um intermediate beginners
or um even
like 23 2400 players would start messing
it up because
they are very focused on what to do in
the queen side that they forgets on they
have other pieces they can advance
other things they can just patiently
wait for opponents to mess up
so what move do you think we should do
and yes it is a good idea to create one
more weakness that is
that's always a good idea the more
weakness the better
i like the idea of h4 honestly but i
think it's um
maybe we can prepare it better with
something like g3 first
yeah we can't play g3 yeah good job
we're gonna do this h4 soon enough
so the whole idea now
king g7 now what do you do now what do
you want to do
no um the one thing that i do not agree
with
is the idea of f3 e4 unfortunately this
doesn't really
work it looks very appealing but the
problem with it is that
um you don't want to give your opponent
chances to
slip away we did some segments of
slippery classes right
phone and sleeping away i sleeping away
so we don't really want to give up one
chance to try and just get away
but um yeah g
turn is just one of those moves so g3
you did it to
prepare better for h4 that is correct
but
the one idea to have on what to do is
kind of like this kink
what do you want to do with your king
because all of your pieces are in a very
interesting position
so now what what shall we do with the
king
also a little hint um take a look at the
title of the class
that should give you a better idea on
what to do with the king right
um king g2 uh
yes possible but f1 is better we kind of
want to go king f1
because um we are hoping to create some
more chances in the king side
now that we have advantage in the queen
side the center is somewhat
just closed up well maybe that's not the
right way to say it it's
still it's not as mobile that would be
dangerous for us
so king f1
yeah well um chest king i'm not sure if
you want to go all the way to d3 but i
do like the idea of getting the king to
b1
so we can go do stuff in the king side
right
so um black is just a little clueless
just waiting around
now what do you think we should do as
white so you know the idea that you want
to get this king to queenside
now all you have to do is figure out the
best way to do it
ah glad to know g2 is making more sense
now
um i was kind of hoping one of you guys
would tell me drink c2 first and then
the king goes
because you don't really if you play
like king to c2 there should there could
be some chances of like take on c6 with
the queen and then play rook c7
so what i'm talking about is even if you
get the king here
there could be some chances for black to
get some
um get some breathing chances so
we don't really want to do that we kind
of want to keep it all tied up
we want to just roxy too just get the
king
to go to his holiday from that side
so um black is still kind of clueless
just waiting around now let's just get
the king
away we finally got our king
to the safe space and um
anybody who wants to talk about what
else black could do
feel free to just let me know in chat if
you see anything
that could look concerning for whites
that black could do
potentially e5 could be something but
even e5 there's always queen d5
and yeah that would be interesting ah
nice to know you guys are watching from
iran glad to know
um because my parents are slain or iran
so i do know that the internet is a huge
problem among other things but
so got to know you are watching
kind of makes me a little more proud
so we got the king to b1
now what we said they want to do stuff
in the king side so
rook b6 doesn't really go with that
spirit
if you wanted to just double the rooks
up you could have done it before you
brought the king
so i don't think that really goes with
the flow
um queen b7 for black
um i think let's just go one move back
so i can actually do this queen b7
i think the problem is what if just take
take and i just played like 4k6 and i'm
picking a 5 up
then i'm just i just have this past pawn
and this is much much
better for um lights now and the game is
pretty winning
so black doesn't really have enough
moves just kind of waiting around
so
um why even move to the queensland last
javier because we want to do stuff in
the king side we want to start upon
march we want to start bringing the
pieces back to go to the queen's
king side so that's what we kind of want
to do
nope none of the moves that i've seen so
far
are suggesting good stuff in the king
side
so i do like the idea of f3 g4 but
you gotta prepare it better you gotta
start bringing a little bit more pieces
to the king side
yeah black doesn't want to strike all
black is doing basically is just
waiting and waiting and just asking you
what do you want to do
so black is just waiting
and it's giving you complete control so
all you have to figure out is how
to use this and the problem is that you
can't really use the see
the c file advantage you can't directly
use it let me put it that way
you can use it to put pressure on all of
the other's opponent's pieces
well um yeah we could try i i do i see
the right move
good job queen e2 very nice cannon
queen e2 yes rook c1 coming up right
right after this one um
so queen e2 is best because
we are hoping to start exploiting this
weaknesses with
g4 with putting direct pressure on h5
so in the game black simply played queen
b7
and i assume his idea was if you were to
play g4 now i can play like queen e7
try to cover up a little bit you take
here i'll just take over there
take this is still pretty better for
white so don't get me wrong i still like
this
more for white but um
g4 would give black some breathing
chances
and for those of you who have watched
any other
video from me you know that i do
i always recommend to just put pressure
on the opponent
even psychologically or kill just on
psychology
and don't let your opponents take
easy out don't let opponents take
easy space so yeah rxc1 good job
everybody
especially prince and others to have
suggested rook c1
so yes rook c1 is the best
one to do right now so after roxy won
um black has some i black as
well black could just keep working
around with the king and see how it goes
which um is what's happened in the game
or black could try to exploit something
like f5 what do you guys think about f5
because f5 is stopping this g4 idea at
least momentarily
so what do you think is the best move
after f5
let me take this g4 air away so you guys
can think
a little bit better um after is
interesting
but f3
i yeah you're still trying with g4 yeah
i think after is okay but it's not the
best move
there is something even more accurate
oops let's do this f5
so what do you think is the most
accurate one
this is actually a very interesting move
so
i'm gonna actually go ahead and call it
a grandmaster level move
so let's see who here is in a grand
master level
i am against playing f4 right now
because if you play f4 you're just
closing everything for yourself
so um cannon a little bit of hints
usually the grandmaster level moves
moves aren't some
casual sacrifice they are something
are a little bit more strategic or one
of those moves that uses oh my god i
just brought this piece from that side
why would i go back
it's usually more of a death style
so i hope this uh this tip helps a
little bit
oh yes good one brought back queen b5
yes you got to do this queen b5 i
i said that i agree f3 g4 is a very
interesting choice
it's i think it works i don't have
anything against it but queen b5
is that one move that kind of blows your
mind
if you play something like queen a8 now
i can play rook b6 now you weakened your
seventh rank
and your e6 so i can't come exploit that
right
uh if you don't play there if you just
simply try to take it
now i have a past pawn and your rick is
kind of
just hanging around for this pawn uh
this bishop
this rook is kind of hanging around for
this pawn
so that's why we like queen b5
we like to we like to just like lay
these little traps for opponent
and just um
wait around and just have easier wins
queen b5 would be an easier win
f3 is is a
interesting move but the problem the not
the problem the one thing that i don't
like about it
[Music]
all right actually bishop g3 thank you
prince in the chat
uh i think rook e6 is still doing good
for black
a bit before fight because rook c6 is
coming so probably rook d6 is the best
move for black
trying to stop that not take take and
maybe still queen b5
maybe e4 now no i think we gotta go with
queen b5 still
and black seems to be kind of holding it
a little bit better
so that's yeah f3 bishop g3 so
exactly not let's not give opponent
chances to slip away
right i don't like slippery opponents i
am a slippery opponent so if you're ever
playing with me
make sure you actually just tie it up
and
don't let me slip away because i i've
shown some segments and twitch in here
i've had some very lost games and i just
kind of ran away with half a point or
the full point
so make sure you keep your points
together because
yeah actually yeah make sure you come
and play us more on twitch because i see
a lot of the youtube viewers or my camp
kids and they
they are not fully informed about
our um our you our twitch channels
so yeah just make sure you come and play
with us i think we're doing again i must
at least there
on thursday and friday probably saturday
too
so talking about f5 and queen b5
now let's say black simply plays this
king g7
now what shall we do do you think um
this is again one of those moves that is
kind of mind-blowing
i do like the idea of playing like f3 g4
but still there's a problem you won't
be able to break through if f3 take on
g3 you don't really you can't even play
rook gt1 because your c6 is falling
so this is not really helpful
i don't have a personal twitch channel
and i am pretty sure i won't
have it this semester at least because
this is my mcat here
and i am trying to just focus on that
at least until january so um
we have the club twitch account just stl
chess just should yeah i think still
chess club that's it
so what should we do in this position
anybody wants to try a queen back to b5
one thing that i will let you know about
petrocyan is that he really really likes
taking his sweet sweet sweet time
so it won't um so whenever you're
looking at petrossians game it's always
a good chance that you repeated
some moves also psychological pressure
that's one of the big things i learned
from
uh reading my system book from nimsovic
and
watching any of petrossian games uh just
repeating a little bit of moves and
getting the opponent in the mindset of
all right maybe my opponent wants to
give me a draw
like nope nope nope no draw for you
today
so um good thinking
um we see queen b5 is the best one queen
c2 or g4
these are some of the moves that still
work but there are just
not the the most accurate one
the problem with g4 is take you take
back
and now what to do you play like okay
six
possible but now uh there's this like
uh it just feels like white is kind of
giving black some
too much breathing room and that's what
i don't like
so we have to figure out what the
opponent wants we played this rook c1
now we got to go back to b5 um
i don't know what is the idea behind
queen c2
so
i i'm a little um uncertain on
what to think about going to do it's
definitely not a bad move it just
i don't really know what's my next move
that's why
so queen b5 um queen e8 is actually the
best one because if
well if he were to take it over here
i'll just take back and we talked about
this end game uh this is a little bit
better version compared to when the pawn
was on f5
but it's still pretty um unpleasant
for black just push that pawn get that
knight
push that pawn a little bit more there
you go b7
oh wait this is pretty lost right all
right hopefully i've convinced you with
my um idea to exchange queens
so if you are actually playing a lower
rated opponent or someone on your level
it is a good idea to lay these little
traps with exchanging stuff
that's what i actually do too um oh my
god i'm sitting here giving up
all of my little techniques oh boy but
yeah because um usually lower rated or
same level opponents are more inclined
to
just wanting to exchange pieces because
they think then there's less pieces to
make them
or less this is for you to take so it is
a good idea to
find an exchange that works in your
favor and do it's like this queen v5
but of course once the gear is onsecure
was also a very
high level grandmaster so he didn't
really
go for those little tricks but
so now we are finally
in a position that we're actually gonna
start doing stuff in the king side so
a little bit of heads up this is a
little
um unorthodox move especially when
you're trying to just attack in the king
side
so white played f4 which i
don't fully understand myself i thought
maybe
g4 right now or e4 i thought e4 might be
a little bit better because if take
then we can just this like a little trap
here again
so um we
are kind of trying to lay a little bit
more traps
that's like i thought e4 was interesting
but then again like we should be seven
maybe we can try or c7 now or e5 maybe
i think these are some um interesting
moves all right so we just talked about
queen b5 queen a8
and f4 so f4 is actually a very good
move
the thing is if you um black waited too
long if he plays f5 now it
is losing because of immediate knight c5
or i also think rook b6 rook c6 is also
pretty lost
for um for black because everything is
just weak over here on the sixth rank
so f5 doesn't work so
owenziger just kind of waited around to
see what's
white's idea and now we finally bring
the queen back
and it is again one of those this game
was one of those games that there were a
lot of repeating so i thought it's also
psychologically interesting to
share so now we
are finally finally finally ready for g4
and the good thing about g4 is that if
you play something like queen e7
now like what we talked before like once
we talked about g4
a little before and there was queen e7
and we talked about this position but
the rook was on c2 and the pawn was on
f2 so we couldn't really um
get the pieces there in time but now we
can we can just play king queen ear and
rook
one and that's that's pretty lost right
one queen should be enough
so let's say take take not queen e7
what do you want to do with whites you
know you have advantage and you have
converted this advantage
from just space to um
well it's still a pretty huge spatial
advantage
but you actually have a clear target you
actually have
a real attack to go after and there was
a question
earlier about what book to do
um i think
the some of the best books that i would
recommend
are so tactics are great playing online
is great
but the best way to actually improve
your chess
is to read the books that have like full
games
or more focused on middle game and are
actually teaching you
how to think what to think have a theme
and um
it's usually a lot of commentary that's
those are good i really like the
girlfriend
books i like the um
dim subways my system books actually up
here
um i like the fisher 16 memorable game
they are there are so many great books
around just make sure you find one that
has commentary in it because part of the
five books from kasparov
um like my great predecessors that's
also a great move
all right good job chess king h5 rakesh
one can come later now let's just do
this h5 first
so in the game black plays queen f6 you
can clearly see that you have advantage
here
but um you just have to kind of be a
little bit more careful on how
you are wrapping up your game so
what does this queen of six want
good metal game book um oh those that's
uh
i think uh just something that's pretty
nice the chapters are pretty nice
are i really like the um the use of both
nine books
they're actually nine books and it has
like three different trios so
that's a very good book to look into it
has has teams it has puzzles
um middle game i think the fisher book
is pretty nice
fisher 16 memorable game
all right so what does the queen want
the queen wants queen f5 check and
exchange your queen
right so let's get away
yeah let's get away from this check
so after king a2 um
blackhand just played kng7 just still
kind of just hanging around seeing
what white wants and white is actually
very um dominance right now so
black is just trying to defend defend
every single move that's white doing and
finally queen back to f2 we want rook g1
right so black tries to kind of copy
paste the idea of running to the other
side with king f8
but it's kind of too late and this is
another great move
that i wish we had more time for me to
actually ask you guys so
if you're watching it later and if you
want to pause it make sure you do it and
think about this move
otherwise knight d2
knight d2 is one of those other moves
like petrossian moves
like you go to b7 i'm just gonna go back
to b3
you go back to b3 and you are giving
your opponents some hopes of repetition
but you have no intentions of doing the
repetitions
because if you actually made the mistake
to play like knight f3 now there's b3 so
careful with those so knight b3
rook goes back to a7 ah queen f
uh not queen h2 now we want to strike g1
queen h8 launch five kind of different
mates
bishop f6 and all right this is actually
another great move
so i'm gonna wait very briefly just to
get one or two responses in the chat
so why to what do you think we should do
it is almost done we are almost very
like
two three more moves left in this game
so
it would be very great if someone could
tell me what to do now
so so you can see that we have advantage
in the queen side we got some stuff
going on in the king side
thank you babak rook c8 good job
if take we would simply take back and
now just f5 this is super winning just
queen goes to b8
and mates coming up rookie 8 mate you're
losing a7
and all right so black simply
played rook d7 now we can bring in the
knight
right if you make the mistake of taking
on c8 i'll pick this up and pick that up
later
so after knight c5 black just played b3
because king takes b3 we're trying to
promote our kings huh
uh in the game black played rook d6 and
i'm just kind of waiting for one final
blow
what do you think it's the best move for
white and
this with this move uh black just gonna
give a check and then resigned
so what do you think is the best move
make sure you always think about music
checks
takes threats we don't really have much
of a
check or take going on because d8 is
still we're kind of just using that
eighth rank as more of a
pressure point yeah good job prince f5
great he just did rick p6 king a2
and black resigned because well the
queen is on
huge trouble this trick isn't a big
problem
tonight whoops nope not fun that one is
actually safe knight d7 is coming up
so yeah uh this was a very interesting
game especially to me psychologically
just
repeating i did learn and i did annoy my
opponents a lot
with this whole repetition stuff so
um i hope you guys learned from this
game as well
and you will use it preferably not
against me when you play me on twitch
channel
but i understand if you do that too so
without much more comments i am gonna
leave you
to go enjoy lars
lecture and i might actually come join
that too as soon as i get a little bit
more coffee
so uh this was a very good uh session i
hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you ben simon
for monitoring it all the way from
the other end and all right
i will